we
previously talked over two years ago
do you think there's still neurons in
your brain that uh remember that
conversation
that uh remember me and got excited like
there's a lex neuron in your brain that
just like finally has a purpose
i do remember our conversation or i have
some memories of it
and i formed additional memories of you
in the meantime
um i wouldn't say there's a neuron or
neurons in my brain that know you
there are synapses in my brain that have
formed
that reflect my knowledge of you and the
model i have of you in the world and
whether the exact same synapses were
formed two years ago it's hard to say
because these things come and go all the
time but
we know from one thing to note about
brains is that when you think of things
you often erase the memory and rewrite
it again so
yes but i have a memory of you and i
have that's instantiated in synapses
there's a simpler way to think about it
like so you have we have a model
of the world in your head and that model
is continually being updated
i updated this morning you offered me
this water you said it was from the
refrigerator
i remember these things and so we and so
the model includes where we live the
places we know the words the
objects in the world it's just a
monstrous model and it's constantly
being updated
and people are just part of that model
so we're animals or
other physical objects so our events
we've done
so um it's there's no special
in my mind special place for the
memories of humans i mean
obviously i know you know i know a lot
about my wife
um but and friends uh and so on but
it's not like a special place for humans
are over here
but we model everything and we model
other people's behaviors too so if i
said you're
a copy of your mind in my mind it's just
because i know how humans
i've learned how humans behave and um
and i've learned some things about you
and that's part of my world model well i
just also mean
the collective intelligence of the human
species
i wonder if there's something
fundamental to the brain that enables
that so modeling
other humans with their ideas you're
you're actually jumping into a lot of
big topics like collective intelligence
is a separate topic that a lot of people
like to talk about we can talk about
that
uh but um and so that's interesting like
you know we're not just individuals we
live in society and so on but from our
research point of view
and so again let's just talk we study
the neocortex it's a sheet of neural
tissue it's about 75
of your brain it runs on this very
repetitive algorithm
it's a very repetitive circuit and so
you can apply that algorithm to lots of
different problems but it's all
underneath it's the same thing we're
just building this model
so from our point of view we wouldn't
look for these special circuits
someplace
buried in your brain that might be
related to other you know understanding
of the humans
it's more like you know how do we build
a model of anything how do we understand
anything in the world and humans are
just another part of the things we
understand
so there's nothing uh there's nothing to
the brain that
knows the emergent phenomena of
collecting intelligence well i certainly
know about that i've heard the terms
i've read
no but that's right well okay right as
an idea well i think we have language
which is is sort of built into our
brains and that's a key
part of collective intelligence so there
are some
you know prior assumptions about the
world we're going to live in when we're
born we're not just
a blank slate um and so you know did we
evolve
to take advantage of those situations
yes but again
we study only part of the brain the
neocortex those other parts of the brain
are very much involved in
societal interactions and human emotions
and
um and how we interact and even societal
um
issues about you know how we are how we
interact with other people when we
support them when we're greedy and
things like that
i mean certainly the brain is a great
place
where to study intelligence i wonder if
it's the fundamental
uh atom of intelligence well i would say
it's it's it's
absolutely an essential component even
if you believe in collective
intelligence as
um hey that's where it's all happening
that's what we need to study which i
don't believe that by the way i think
it's really important but i don't think
that is the thing
um but even if you do believe that then
you have to understand how the brain
works in doing that
um it's you know it's more like we are
intelligent and we are intelligent
individuals and together we are much
more magnified our intelligence we can
do things that we couldn't do
individually
but even as individuals we're pretty
damn smart and we can model things and
understand the world and interact with
it
so to me if you're going to start some
place you need to start
with the brain then you could say well
how do brains interact with each other
and what is the nature of language and
how do we
share models that i've learned something
about the world how do i share it with
you which is really what
you know sort of communal intelligence
is i know something you know something
we've had different experiences in the
world i've learned something about
brains maybe i can impart that to you
you've learned something about
you know whatever physics and you can
port that to me
but it also comes down to even just the
epistemological question of
well what is knowledge and how do you
represent it in the brain right
it's not that's where it's going to
reside right for in our writings
it's obvious that uh human collaboration
human interaction
is how we build societies right but some
of the things you
talk about and work on
some of those elements of what makes up
an intelligent
entity is there with a single person oh
absolutely i mean
we can't deny that the brain is the core
element here in
in uh at least i can't i think it's
obvious the brain is the core element of
all theories of intelligence
uh it's where knowledge is represented
it's where knowledge is created
um we interact we share we build upon
each other's work
but uh without a brain you'd have
nothing you know there would be no
intelligence without brains
and so um so that's where we start i got
into this field because i just was
curious as to who i am
you know how you know how do i think
what's going on in my head when i'm
what i'm thinking what does it mean to
know something you know i can ask what
it means for me to know something
independent of how i learned it from
you or from someone else or from society
so what does it mean for me to know that
i have a model of you in my head what
does it mean to know i know what this
microphone does and how it works
physically even though i can't see it
right now
how do i know that what does it mean how
the neurons do that at the fundamental
level of neurons and synapses and so on
those are really fascinating questions
and i'm happy to
be just happy to understand those if i
could
you